Good afternoon. Thank you for joining us this afternoon for our session,
From Risk Awareness to Informed Action Advancing Cancer
Communication Across Prevention and Genomic
Care. We have three speakers today.
Dr. Jeffrey Niederdeppe from
Cornell University in Ithaca, New York, Sarah
Bauerly Bass from Philadelphia Temple University,
and I'm Anita Kinney, and I'm at Rutgers Cancer Institute and Rutgers
University. So this session is focused on strengthening cancer risk
communication across prevention, screening, and precision
oncology. And the session highlights evidence-based communication
strategies to help individuals, communities
understand modifiable cancer risk factors, reduce
disparities, and translate complex information
into informed action. So our first speaker is Dr.
Niederdeppe. Thank you.
All right. Thanks, Anita.
Again, Jeff Niederdeppe, Cornell University.
And some of the work that I'm going to present today is
supported by grants from NCI and NIH and reflect,
of course,
my own responsibility and not these agencies.
So to start, I'm going to focus my comments today on the
prevention and detection stages of the cancer
control continuum. Not to say that some of the methods and
approaches are not appropriate for questions about treatment
and survivorship, but the focus of my work is predominantly prevention and
detection.
And I'm going to make three main points today.
The first point I'm going to make, and I'll walk you through each of these, is that
strategic and effective health communication often starts with the
outcome you want to achieve and works backward, rather than starting with
the message you want to convey and working forward.
Second, the public communication environment, including
increasingly, importantly, social media around cancer
prevention behaviors, is competitive and complex, and we need to understand that
competitiveness and complexity to message effectively.
And third, that well-designed formative and evaluative messaging
research can offer evidence-based strategies for effective
cancer communication.
So let me start with this first premise, that strategic behavior change
starts with the outcome and works backward.
When you work in cancer prevention or
preventive medicine in general, we're around people all the time who are always
thinking about cancer, and links between various risk
factors and cancer. And I'm going to walk through a thought example
here focused on messaging around the link between
alcohol and cancer, a known risk factor.
And if we start from the perspective of
there's a link between alcohol and cancer and drinking less is good,
we often may be tempted to say, "That's the message we need to convey if we want
to promote people to drink less alcohol."
But decades of theory and research on behavior
change communication suggests that it's often productive to
start with the outcome and work backward to understand the various
kinds of beliefs that people hold about that behavior.
Some of which may be links between, for instance, health risks and the
behavior, but some of which may be about other things that are driving
whether or not people choose to drink more or less.
And so you can see some examples here.
Certainly, some people
are driven by beliefs about alcohol and cancer, but others may
be motivated by other
health risks or mental health or just feeling
better, for instance. Beliefs about the social risks about alcohol may be
driving whether or not people choose to drink less or more.
Beliefs about the benefits of drinking.
It's going to be a fun time or loosened inhibitions may be
driving the behavior. Normative beliefs, what my friends do, what my colleagues do,
and whether or not I even could, if I wanted to, drink
less alcohol.
Lots of work suggests that trying to understand which of these beliefs is
driving the behavior and then developing messaging interventions to target
those beliefs that are most important in shaping the behavior can lead
to more effective messaging strategies.
And that may include beliefs about, for instance,
alcohol and cancer, but it may not.
Also, if we start with the outcome and work backwards, we may open up different
kinds of interventions or strategies that might prove to be effective.
For instance, we know that reducing alcohol marketing or
availability predicts less drinking.
We know that increasing the cost, financial, of alcohol or the social
cost of drinking, sanctions for drink driving, for
instance, are associated with drinking less alcohol.
And that may lead us to a different or similar set of
messaging strategies that target whether or not people support or oppose these
kinds of policies, which in turn create better, healthier
environments for drinking less alcohol.
All right. Second point I want to make here is that the public communication
environment for cancer prevention behaviors, and lots of other behaviors for that
matter, is competitive and complex, and that there is value to
understanding it to identify opportunities for
effective messaging.
On the competitive side, I think it goes without saying, but I think illustrating
the volume is quite illustrative, that messaging about,
say, alcohol
cancer and drinking
less occurs in a competitive messaging environment where there are lots
of companies who are messaging all about the ways that drinking more is
a good thing. This is true for lots and lots of behaviors.
Here I'm showing you data just based on its availability about impressions and
expenditures by food and beverage companies.
This data is from 2020 and 2021. And what we see here
is thatFood and beverage companies spent,
over a one-year period, over
$2.7 billion marketing
food and beverages,
most likely not focusing on the health impacts of these.
So I raise this just to say that any messaging we're doing is
in competition with commercial marketing forces who
dramatically outspend us, and we need to understand what kinds of messages are
being conveyed about the products or behaviors that we are competing with
in cancer risk or health communication.
The second point I'll make here is that people are seeking and
accessing health information from a wide range of sources, some of which
may be credible and some of which may be not.
These are data from a recent study, March 2025,
on US women ages 21 to 65.
The sources that they cited, seeking information about
cervical cancer
as a topic. And what we see here is that, yes,
women in this age group are looking at health websites.
About 73% say they look for information about cervical cancer from health
websites, from search engines. But we also see some sort of maybe
less obvious sources here. Social media,
44% mention seeking
information about cervical cancer.
Generative AI, 40%. I bet you that number's higher today
than it was even a year ago.
And if you look at these numbers by women and men, for that matter, who
are at the younger distribution of this age
range, those numbers are actually quite a bit higher,
social media, generative AI, for younger populations.
So the centrality of social media platforms,
particularly for young people, changes some things
about health communication and what we need to know and understand, but it doesn't
change everything. And I want to say a little bit about what I think it changes
and a little bit about what I think it doesn't change.
So what's different? Well, for one, social media platforms
favor video over text, and they make it difficult
to identify the original source of the message because they're often messages that
are shared or reposted with editorial and commenting and
things like that, which make it difficult to know where that message came from
originally. Social media platforms privilege short messages
over ones that have more nuance and complexity, and when we're dealing with cancer,
we're often dealing with nuance and complexity.
They rely on message retransmission, so we have to care not only
about whether people see our messages, but whether or not people are sharing them
and distributing them at scale, because the networked
nature of our social media environments mean that a lot of the
chances of whether or not people see a message depend on whether people are sharing
those messages. But we also lose some control of the message when people
share it, repost, comment, etc.
They're inherently relational, meaning that we get information from people who are
like us on social media platforms, and those messages tend to
reinforce our existing beliefs and can encourage confirmation
bias, things we think we already know.
And finally, they may not reflect expert perspectives or
messaging about cancer and health that we, in the cancer
prevention space, would want or assume that
people would
need to be exposed to.
Let me give you an example of what this looks like on social media messages
about cancer. Here, we have a study led by my colleague Andy King
of messages about five different
cancers. You see there in this chart, breast
cancer, colon cancer, esophageal cancer, liver cancer, and oral cancer.
All cancers that are associated
with
reduced risk of drinking, as predicts onset of these cancers.
And this is a sample of messages that used these hashtags or hashtags
that are similar to these on Twitter between 2019 and
2021. The point I want to make here, if you look at the far right
column, is that messages that talk about these cancers on social media
almost never mention alcohol. Even for liver cancer,
it's less than 2% of messages
mention alcohol. And in some cases, when alcohol is mentioned, it's not
a risk message, but it's instead a sort of alcohol sponsor or a
pro alcohol message. So this is to say messages
about these cancers on social media are not talking
about the role of cancer, for instance.
We also are looking at messages on TikTok.
This is data from an ongoing study where we're looking at
specifically hashtags that are focused on either
alcohol reduction, drinking less, or alcohol
cessation, quitting drinking entirely.
And these are messages that have appeared on TikTok between 2021 and
2025. And I'll point out two things from these data.
One is that a lot of the
messages on TikTok that are tagged with hashtags that say things like "drink
less" or "drink responsibly" actually aren't about alcohol at all.
The vast majority of these are not directly relevant to this topic.
But even when they are, they almost never mention cancer
as a reason to drink less or as a reason to not
drink at all, to
be cessation from alcohol. And so I raise this to say, for those
of us who are spending our lives thinking about different carcinogens and different
risk factors for cancer and increasingly
focusing, I think, on the role of alcohol,
this is not so much happening in the social media platforms in which people are
getting lots of their information.
So this is both an opportunity and a challenge, right?
We have a messaging environment that's not amplifying messages
about alcohol, but potentially a chance to do so through our own
interventions.Now, what's the same about
social media?
I said before that some things are different.
I talked about what's different, but lots of principles are exactly the same.
Public health communication has always had to meet audiences where
they are, whether on TV,
online, or on social media. That has not changed, despite that
people's media habits have changed, and we need to follow them.
We've always had to compete with well-funded industry forces who
spend more money than we'll ever have in prevention, and public
health, and cancer prevention. We've always needed to identify
credible sources to communicate about public health.
Now, the nature of those sources, who is found credible, may
evolve over time. We're at a moment when certainly public health is not
experiencing high levels of public trust, but that doesn't change the fact that we
need to identify sources that are seen as credible by our audiences.
We need to learn and create opportunities for exchange and
feedback on the messages that we're developing from
audiences who are experiencing the world, likely in different ways
than we are from our
roles as health communicators or in the
health system.
And finally, we've always needed to find ways to invite people to engage
with more complex, longer form messages for
complicated and uncertain science related to cancer
prevention.
All right. I'm going to spend the last couple of minutes talking about making a
case that well-designed, formative, and evaluative messaging
research can offer evidence-based guidance
for effective cancer communication, although it's not a panacea
either.
The way that we tend to approach studying and developing messages
for cancer prevention begins with what I've already talked about, trying to
understand what messages are out there in our health websites, in news
articles, and in social media to understand what people are seeing in
their daily lives.
And then to learn how people are responding to these messages by sampling
them, and then doing various methods to crowdsource
or to identify messages that seem to resonate among diverse
audiences, including populations who experience disparities.
And then take that information and formally test the impact of these messages
using tried and true methods like randomized control trials that I'm sure
are quite familiar to folks in this room to provide strong,
causal, evidence-based guidance.
Let me walk you through an example of what we've done recently in this space.
I'm switching now to a focus on a project that is promoting
colorectal cancer screening.
And in this study, we sampled over 2,000
Black and White Americans of
screening-recommended eligible age, 45 to 74,
who had no prior colorectal cancer diagnosis.
And we recruited them from a panel in '23 and
'24 that seeks to use probability
sampling to develop what are reasonable approximations for a
nationally representative sample.
And in this study, what we did is we gave them what's called a wiki
survey, which is functionally a choice experiment where
you ask people to choose between two messages, which they
find more or less persuasive. And in this case, we gave them an opportunity to
nominate their own user-generated messages for
potential inclusion. And so we sampled about
63 messages from the public communication environment, from social media and
health websites, and we added 30 or so more
user-generated messages for testing.
So what does this look like? Respondents were shown 20 pairs of messages,
and each of them were asked to read each message, message
A and message B, and we asked them, "Which of these messages
is more likely to make you, A, want to get screened for
colorectal cancer? Or B, given how messages
transmit in social media, which would you be more likely to
share with your family and friends?" And then if they wanted to, they had the
option to add an additional message, which we read and
screened and added several into our choice set.
And so
after making sense of these data, what we can do is rank these messages in terms
of ones that were perceived as more or less effective.
And in this case, what we did is we stratified our sample by race because
it turned out that information on which
messages were perceived as highly effective and shareable differed pretty
substantially between White and Black Americans.
So what I'm showing you here is our top five rated messages among White Americans.
I'm not going to ask you to read these messages, but I'll point out just a couple
of things. One, messages that were rated highly among White respondents were
generally also rated highly among Black respondents.
Maybe not quite the first, second, or third, but still top
quartile or so.
And the one in italics was a user-generated message,
suggesting there's pretty substantial value to understanding and
learning from a crowdsourcing and user-generated way.
If we turn to messages that were perceived as most effective by Black respondents,
we see a very different pattern. The first, second,
and fourth rated message among African Americans or Black respondents
were rated as some of the lowest perceived effective
among White respondents. And it's pretty clear, I think, to see
what is driving that. Messages that were rated as highly effective
among Black respondents tended to specify that we were speaking to
African Americans, Black men, Black women, Black people, African
Americans in these messages. And White respondents very
much rated these in their own terms as less
potentially effective. There were a couple messages, again, number three and
five among Black Americans, that were also rated as highly
effective among White Americans, but these did not specify anything about the
racial identity of the potential audience or
risk of colorectal cancer.So then
we took this information, and we wanted to sort of validate whether or not
these perceived message effectiveness ratings would translate
into changing actual intentions to adhere to screening guidelines.
So we took another sample. We're using the same panel, NORC
AmeriSpeak, of about 1,000 white respondents and about 1,000 Black respondents.
But these were different people,
so not the same respondents. And we randomized them into five treatment
arms. And folks who received a messaging condition saw
six different social media posts.
And then we compare intentions to adhere to screening recommendations
and message sharing intentions by message condition and racial group.
This is what the randomization looks like.
We had a control group who saw nothing. They just answered the questions.
They're our comparison group. And then we have four messaging conditions.
The first saw messages that were about average, median ranked by
everyone. A second group saw messages that were preferred by white
Americans in our previous study. The third group saw messages that were
preferred by Black Americans in our previous study.
And the fourth sort of final treatment group had messages
that were, overall, by both white and Black Americans, perceived as being
highly effective. Were they actually effective?
Just to give you a sense, these are what these messages looked like.
They were like a social media post, but we didn't make them platform
specific and took the text from our previous arm of the
study.
So turning to results, I'm showing you results here for Black adults
ages 45 to 74, and we see here that first,
every single messaging condition produced higher levels of intentions to adhere to
screening recommendations than people who got no message at all.
But we see sort of the highest mean levels happening for those
who saw either Black preferred messages or overall preferred
messages. But the median scored messages fared pretty well.
The white preferred messages scored a little less favorably.
But for white respondents, none of the messages moved the needle on increasing
adherence to screening recommendations, regardless of whether they were targeted,
preferred, or not.
Finally, if we look at intentions to share, we see a pretty clear pattern
here, where Black preferred messages were more likely to
be intended to be shared by Black respondents, and white preferred
messages were less likely to be shared by Black respondents.
And the flip side was true for white respondents who were more likely to want to
share messages that, in the previous study, white respondents had preferred.
So I will close by saying what I said at the beginning,
that decades of behavior change theory, research, and evidence
suggests that effective health communication starts with the outcome you want and
works backwards, rather than starting with a message about risk
and moving from there.
That the public communication environment is complex,
and
understanding it reveals both gaps in messaging but also
opportunities for effective communication.
And that well-designed formative research can offer
evidence-based guidance. But this is not a panacea by any stretch.
It's not a guarantee we're going to see effectiveness.
And
I think Sarah will speak a lot about this idea that segmenting
audiences by meaningful differences in message preferences and message
risk is tremendously important and underscored by our
data here.
I will stop there and open it up for questions. Thank you.
I just ask that people come to the mic because we have people streaming, and so
they need to be able to hear you. Thank you.
Go ahead.
Thanks a lot. Suzanne de la Loge from France. I have two questions.
The first is,
well, how much are participative messages, meaning
messages that have been concepted with
real people, how much do they
impact the results that you observe versus non-participative messages?
So the messages that we were testing, they were a combination of messages
that were user-generated and generated from laypeople, but
also by accounts like the American Cancer Society and
NIH and other sorts of cancer centers.
So it was a combination of both expert, I guess I would say, designed
messages and lay-designed messages.
But in both cases, some of the user-designed messages rose to
the top. They were some of the messages that were perceived as at
least in the upper tier of message effectiveness.
So I think it speaks to the fact that there's value in both.
Obviously, those messages from expert sources I think are
designed with
some research and evidence behind them.
But spending some time understanding what emerges naturally, I think
also can help us understand how people are thinking about these
issues.
Well, and a secondary question to that would be that some of the messages are quite
biased in terms of science, et cetera.
They're very appealing. And in terms of ethics, I
don't know, in my country, some of these messages might be forbidden.
Not considered ethic because imbalanced, et cetera.
So it's always a balance between what we should do,
what is used outside of medicine and science.
So I don't know how to answer that question, but...
Yeah, I'll say two things. One, we
sort of curated them a bit. We did not include any messages that included anything
that was factually wrong. That was incorrect.
So some were saying, like, "Oh, you need to get screened when you're 18."
But there are cases where colonoscopies are helpful for people who are 18 if a
doctor is recommending that based on-...
symptoms or family history, but that's not the screening recommendation, and so we
didn't do anything that was outside of evidence-based communication.
But that is to say, some of the messages focus on things that are not an
emphasis of clinical research, talking about
how the process of getting a colonoscopy, for
instance. Or, "The prep isn't as bad as you think,
and the trade-off is worth it." So these are messages, I think,
that aren't
reporting on scientific evidence per se, but are about lived
experience of engaging in the behaviors. But I agree with you.
It's very important, obviously, not to be spreading factually
false information, and you need
some mechanism of screening and curation in order to do that.
Okay, and a small last question. Well, it's not small, but
it's always so striking to me that
religious messages on alcohol, especially, are so efficient.
It's both religious and community, but
well, it's incredible to me almost every day that it's so efficient
as compared to whatever we can do to prevent people from
drinking, for instance. And
I'm just wondering how much we should work on that and see what
that kind of mechanism, could it be used outside of religious and
community context? And
of course, it's very different, but
well, the solution could be there.
Yeah. I think
the interaction between the source and the content of the message is really, really
important, right? I'm not sure that I want my primary care provider
bringing religious themes into the messaging about my
risk or my behaviors. So there are some kinds of messages that an
oncologist or a doctor is going to be well-positioned to do, but there are other
kinds of messages, and I think from a prevention and
campaign development perspective, identifying partners who
share the same goal and yet have different sources
of trust or credibility with audiences.
So certainly, religious leaders or even just other everyday
people who
are choosing
to drink less or not drink at all, in these cases, due to religious reasons,
that's going to resonate with some people.
And some people are going to be more credible messengers of that kind of
message than others.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Hi. A little more general question.
I was just wondering if any work has been done or if there's any information
available that addresses
a distrust that the public tends to have sometimes of healthcare
scientists or even their own doctors.
I was wondering if there's anything about how
that impacts the ability to get those messages across that we're trying to
communicate,
or any strategies that can address that.
Yeah. Great question.
So yes, there's lots of work that has been looking at declining
trust in institutions, declining trust, certainly, in
our federal messengers about
health. But your
own primary doctor has held pretty steady over
that time, generally speaking. There's also obvious social patterns
and historical reasons why different populations distrust medical
systems and authorities.
Some of them well-earned due to racism and
discrimination in health systems, for instance.
And so, I think it goes back to this idea of
needing to identify credible sources who may or may not be
institutional actors, who may or may not be
people wearing a white coat in a
laboratory or in a clinical setting.
That's going to differ depending on which audience you're engaging with.
So there's not one sort of size-fits-all kind of
credible source for all sorts of information.
That said,
primary care physicians still, I think, have quite a bit of
trust for those
people who have access to primary care and have a doctor
that they've built a relationship with over time.
So those remain very important relationships that
are constrained by lots and lots of factors
as to how long those interactions can be,
frequency of engagement with doctors.
So I think without a doubt, there's a need to think more broadly
than simply within health systems about messaging.
But who are those resonant audiences, I think, is a moving
target over time, and that's the role of formative research, is
to identify who those groups are that resonate at the community level for
particular populations.
Thank you.
Yeah. Quick question about the study in terms of the messaging.
So were those, I guess people were reading it,
or is it a video, or if there's a difference between that.
Yeah, of course. So the study where we were
randomly assigning people to see messages, those were text-based
messages, and they looked like mock-up social media messages.
Some of the studies that we've done to understand what's out there are making use
of video messages. So our TikTok study, that's taking messages
that are anywhere from 60 seconds-- Well, less than that, 10
seconds to two or three minutes, and then we're using
various computational generative AI strategies
to synthesize what's in those messages, to
extract information from the video and then make sense of them
to understand what kinds of messages they're conveying.
So it's a combination, and certainly, I think when you introduce
images and video, you're adding complexity to the messages.
So for something like a randomized controlled trial where you're trying to hold
some things constant, it adds noise and variability.
But the flip side is that'sHow lots of people are seeing
messages. And so absolutely, it matters.
And absolutely, I think thinking about the interaction between
video and what's shown in a video and what's put in a
message is important. And there's an emerging body of research
on how to think about those things in the context of cancer, how
different kinds of visual information shapes how people make sense.
But there's also a lot to learn in that space.
Thank you.
Thanks.
And I think we're at time. Thank you very much.
All right. Thank you.
Good afternoon, everyone. Thanks for
being here. Jeff set it up very well for me.
It was like we almost planned this, right?
So I'm going to talk a little bit today about especially
commercial marketing techniques, segmentation, and some of the
data-based methods that I'm using in my
lab. So quick overview of what we're going to do is just a little bit about
the health communication process,
the use of these marketing techniques, specifically looking at
segmentation. And then I'm going to talk about a technique called
perceptual mapping and vector message modeling.
And then I'm going to show you how I've applied these types of
methods to the development of an electronic
decision tool for Black patients around tumor
genomic profile testing.
So this is a very iconic
figure in health communication for those of us who work in health comm.
And it's really this process of thinking about how do you
develop, as Jeff was talking about, really
well-developed, formatively
based health communication messages.
And the stages would be planning the strategic
development, doing that formative work of understanding who your audience
is,
developing these messages and concept testing them, which is what really
Jeff was talking about here.
Assessing the effectiveness of those messages by actually testing them
on some types of outcomes,
and then refining them
to see if you needed to make any changes as you go.
One of the things we have to think about with health comm too is what is our
overall goal in what we're trying to do, right?
Are we trying to persuade people to do something,
to take that next step, to get a colonoscopy, to get screened for
something, to stop drinking alcohol,
about some type of decision-making behavior, or are we just trying to
provide information to increase knowledge or awareness
of something? And depending on what your answer is to that is
how you might go about the development of those things
and the testing of those things.
The challenge, however, in health communication-- So Jeff talked a lot about
how many messages are actually out there.
But in general, health messages often fail to change
behavior.
Because often what we do is we use a
one-size-fits-all
method, where we think that if this message works
in one population, it's going to work in all populations.
And that information alone does not really
equal behavior change overall. And so the
need really is for health communication to have
targeted, very audience-centric
strategies to be able to develop messages, and those strategies might be
different across different populations.
So one of the things that we can do then is to use marketing techniques to
understand these audiences. And this is how commercial marketers do it
all the time, right? This is how they get us to buy products.
Different types of
soda or different types of cereal, all of those
kinds of things. And the idea is that they put an enormous
emphasis on who that population is or who that
audience is and what they actually want.
So, the idea behind this is that to
influence an audience, we have to understand who that
audience is and what the determinants are of the
behavior that we're interested in.
And the mission for us is to know who those, and I put it in quotation marks,
"customers" are,
and what they need to be able to make a
decision about what we're trying to do.
And one of the ways that we can do that is to apply these very
commercial marketing techniques to health
communication, one of which is segmentation.
This idea of segmentation analysis, and then I'm going to talk a
little bit about what personas are.
So Abe Lincoln, this is paraphrased, obviously.
"You may please all the people some of the time.
You may even please some of the people all the time, but you can't please
all the people all of the time." And that's really the background of what
segmentation is. Which is a traditional
market segmentation. It's a strategy for dividing a broad segment
into subsegments or distinctive groups that have some type of
commonality to one another.
When we're doing it, we ask ourselves things like, would it be useful
to separate users of a product from the non-user?
So, people who smoke versus who don't. So that might be a behavior.
Jeff was talking about more racial differences in
subgroups.
Are there separate groups that require different types of information that
might motivate them to change based on that?
And are there groups that are likely to identify with different sources of
information or different providers of that
information? And if the answer is yes, then segmentation is something
that you might be able to use, because people do
differ. They differ by their health knowledge.
They differ by their motivations and beliefs.
They
differ in their access to different things, their social
norms, cultural norms,
their life views,
non-traditional health-related beliefs, those kinds of
things. And communication is filtered through all of these different
differences that make it very important.So
CDC has this method called the GROUP method.
Gather, restructure, outline, use, and profile.
CDC always has an acronym. But this idea is,
first that we need to gather information about our audience and
understand what potential differences there might be, and that
might be through just epidemiological data.
But it also may be through knowledge, attitude, and beliefs and behavior
types of surveys, or qualitative work that you might
do where you're looking at social norms or skills or self-efficacy,
and you also might look at demographics.
And then we might potentially take that
information that we do to restructure them into different
segments. And we might do that by differences in demographics, by
differences in beliefs, in differences by
psychographics, and psychographics is really just this idea of
attitude differences across populations.
It might be by theoretical constructs, et cetera.
And then we might outline and use those by thinking about this kind
of large target population and then looking at them
in these
subpopulations to decide
which of these subpopulations it makes sense for us to actually
focus on.
And then we might profile. So here's an example.
This is a family planning
example where you might have a large potential audience of women
of reproductive age, but then we might look at possible
segments by things like sociodemographic differences.
So maybe older versus younger mothers,
might be beliefs around
family planning in general because of religious
areas. It might be geographical differences.
It might be behavioral differences where maybe they've recently
discontinued a use of family planning method, or they
currently use a family planning method.
Or it might be the psychographic differences.
So things like their values about,
or beliefs about family planning.
Another piece of segmentation is we can use what we call user profiles
or personas. And the idea of a
persona is that you actually make up
someone based on these segments that you've found.
So you might assign them a name, an
age, a geographic area that they're living in, a
profile summary of who that person is, maybe personality or
psychographic beliefs, their motivations, their frustrations.
And this is a way for you as the
communicator to think through who are these different
groups, right? So this is not a real person.
This is
based on the formative work that you might do to come up with what
these different personas are, to help you think about what messaging
might be best
focused or targeted towards that kind of a person.
Overall, the benefits of segmentation include
increasing message relevance,
it can improve engagement and comprehension, and it can
enhance that trust and credibility, especially if you are
making sure that you're addressing those key areas that are going to be important
to that particular group.
The next section that I do then is to think about, how do
we now take that segmentation and actually start to develop
messaging? And so I use a process called perceptual mapping and vector message
modeling.
It's a commercial marketing technique again, in telling us,
who
buys a Coke versus a Pepsi, right? How do we get someone to buy a
Coke? And in my lab at Temple, what we're trying to
do is, how do we get someone to buy a health
decision, right? So maybe it's a vaccine, maybe it's a
colonoscopy, which this guy doesn't look very excited about, or maybe
it's taking some type of medication.
And the idea here is, can we see inside someone's
mind in understanding how they might be feeling about
someone by using mathematical means to do so?
So the methodology, it uses multidimensional scaling, and
then we use a process called vector modeling technique.
And these models are three-dimensional, and it allows us to play around
with it, like a physics model, to understand how could we maybe get
a group to move towards the decision that we're most interested in.
And this is what one looks like. Obviously, I don't have the time to go in depth
here.
You can go to my website or certainly talk with me
about this. But it's a graphic display of how respondents perceive
relationships among something. So you might have this group of folks,
and you might have these different variables
that might make them more or less likely to do something.
And then you actually have
whatever the target decision is or the behavior that you're
interested in. And we use very traditional survey
measures where people are rating things on how
much they agree or disagree about something.
And it doesn't really require them to think really abstractly.
And then we use this process of vector modeling, where we're trying to
think about how do we move people in this three-dimensional space
where we can maybe think about what's going to be most
persuasive to get them to move.
So here's an example of one, and we were talking about mistrust here.
That was one of our psychographic things, was looking at mistrust in
Black cancer patients and thinking about
what might be messages that we need to
really think about incorporating into decision
support to get them to actually move that.
And we can use that with segmentation by looking at people maybe who
have higher levels of mistrust versus lower levels of
mistrust, and how differences in that messaging might
be different.What this allows us to
do is kind of think about, I always tell my students, we tend
to want to throw the kitchen sink at everyone by telling them everything
about everything and people actually get overwhelmed that way.
We don't need all that information to decide if we're going to buy a Coke.
And so a lot of this is psychological
and we have to think about what is going to be most persuasive to move people
towards things. Segmentation can identify kind of who those
people are,
and perceptual mapping then reveals kind of how those folks
think.
And the vector messaging identifies what message
strategies are likely to be most persuasive.
And then together, if we think about those, we can really create
very audience-specific plans,
and it allows us for really targeting and
tailoring those strategies for each segment that we might identify
as potentially different from one another.
So, in my last couple minutes, I'm going to talk about how
we've applied these methods specifically to a decision support
tool that we've developed called GenePilot.
So, the background on this is the fact that
tumor genomic profile testing is getting done on pretty much
all patients, but often the patients are not being told
that this
is one of the cadre of tests that is getting done.
And one of the issues with that is that with this type of
testing, you also might get secondary germline
hereditary types of results that could also have
implications for a patient and their family. Right?
And so for a lot of those folks, they don't know this.
It might be quite new to them. And so the idea behind GenePilot
was that we wanted to make sure, especially if people had
more levels of mistrust, that they understood, number one, that this
test was being done, but that also
these types of results might happen and that they
have the power to decide what they want to do with that information, whether they
want to be told that information then, if they want to delay it,
if they want to include their family in it,
those kinds of things.
So we did a lot of formative work
for this, where we did qualitative focus groups with, and this was
specifically with Black cancer patients,
and in-depth interviews with oncologists.
We did these quantitative surveys where we then did segmentation
analysis, and we did perceptual mapping and vector message modeling.
And then we started to develop this tool with
really extensive input, kind of an iterative process with a
community advisory board, with patients, and then doing concept
and usability testing of this tool.
Just to give you a quick background, we found in our qualitative work
that there were kind of six major themes that we had found
about this type of testing. The
preference for knowing about a genetic risk,
an understanding that genetic testing, and you can see here it was
this idea that a form of institutional racism that's involved
in treatment and feeling very unsure about the fact that this
testing was being done. Definitely levels of
medical mistrust, talking about decision-making and what they
should do with that information,
having family support or not around kind of the
cancer journey, and then how we communicate those results.
The quantitative piece, we surveyed over 100 Black cancer
patients and 50 oncologists,
and then did the
segmentation, perceptual mapping, and vector message modeling.
This gives you an idea. We looked specifically at medical mistrust with low
and high, and you can see how they differ on these different
items.
And that this was clearly a
psychographic difference of segmentation to try and
understand how trust might be related to how they felt about
having this.
And this shows you that these two clusters are completely different from
each other by demographics. And this is a really important piece too, is that
sometimes we think about, okay, these are all Black cancer patients, that somehow
they're all going to be the same.
And what we find is that when you dive down into these
psychographic issues, that with medical mistrust, you
see that these are not
being confounded by demographics in any way.
This is one of the perceptual maps, just to give you an idea of, these were
people that had high mistrust. And what we saw was that
messaging around fear that genetic information won't be kept
private,
that the testing is being done to get more money out of them
and their insurance,
and that people with genetic diseases might be discriminated
against, were all really important for us to kind of
address in this decision tool. Whereas those with low
levels of mistrust, the genetic info used against me because of my
race was still important to them, but we didn't see
those other things. Then we take those, and we think
about it from a messaging standpoint.
So what are these key concerns, and how do they differ
between kind of high mistrust and low mistrust?
And then we identify, can we kind of think about
how to put that into a decision tool so that
if you have people who have high or low levels of mistrust, that they would have
content that would address their issues.So
GenePilot is an electronic decision tool that
is web-based, so it can be shown on an iPad in the clinic,
or it can be seen at home
using their own technology.
It has voiceover, easy navigation.
It is multicultural but addresses the issues for Black patients from the
formative work. And we found that actually from our concept testing, which is
our Black cancer patients did not like the fact that everybody in it
had a Black face.
It has four different sections. It's called Fly,
Glide, Soar, and Navigate.
The Fly is just an overview of information.
Glide are the personas. So we develop personas very
similar to what I was talking about.
Soar, where they can see real patient testimonials, and then
Navigate, which allows them to interact with different
choices. And then based on whatever they choose, they get a
pre-populated list of potential questions that they can ask their
doctor, and they can have that printed, or they can have it emailed to
them.
So this just gives you a few screenshots
of the different
pieces.
These are our personas. And you can see here that
one of the ways that we address mistrust, so James was one of our personas.
James is 56, has lung cancer, is suspicious of the medical
system and insurance companies. He's heard about researchers doing
experiments on patients, et cetera.
And then if that resonated with someone, they could then
click on that and then there would be an
animated video. And that really it does address
those kinds of things.
This is Soar. So again, these are our patient testimonials, and then this is
what a Navigate would look like once they have chosen the topics that
they're interested in. And then it self-populates those
pieces.
So I would say just final thoughts on some of this is that the
use of these commercial marketing techniques can be a really important tool to
developing targeted and highly persuasive communication
materials and interventions. So GenePilot, we
did one RCT with that. We saw very significant
results around
decisional conflict and just self-efficacy about what
people would want to do with genetic information afterwards.
It can ensure that you're really targeting to different groups,
and this perceptual mapping idea can also really
key in on things that might be most persuasive because you
have this combined approach. And it helps us think
more strategically about intervention objectives so
that the patients that we're trying to provide information to
can really benefit.
And that's me. So thank you. I'm happy to answer any questions.
Hi. I'm curious, has your lab done any studies in terms
of what patients perceive or what
types of providers or types of provider communication patients
perceive as trustworthy versus not?
Because at the end, even if they go through the tool, they will still have a
face-to-face discussion with the provider.
And
how do you have that discussion and leave
them with a sense of confidence that you have their best interests in
mind?
Yeah, that's a great question. So this project specifically was
funded by the American Cancer Society, and we actually had a dual second piece
where we developed an intervention for
oncologists as well to try and help them
understand the issues that Black patients might be feeling
about this tumor testing.
And we did do that. So I didn't talk about that particular
piece.
But I think you're right in that this is important for
informed decision-making. So hopefully the patient is coming to the
physician to say, "Hey,
did I have this test? This is what I'm thinking," asking them
questions, and that they're able to respond to those questions.
And I think that that's an important kind of adjunct
piece of that communication that has to happen.
But what we've also seen is that especially in
populations that might have more levels of mistrust,
that they don't feel as comfortable having those discussions with their
physician. And so it might be better for them to get this
outside of that dyad so that they can
then come into the dyad feeling that they have some self-efficacy
or self-empowerment to talk about it.
I have a question.
So great presentation and really interesting work.
How do you
assess engagement with GenePilot?
Like how many people actually open the app?
How many people really use it, go through the whole
required components?
Sure. Yeah. So
you
can track that within the web-based system.
So we do it on Amazon Web Services, and we're able to see how many
people have clicked through, what parts of the
app that they have used.
Also, we do some
survey at the end. So they do it, and they can't get
access to the survey unless they've gotten to the last screen.
And then that post-test also asks them some questions about
how they feel about different pieces of it, what they see the utility of those
pieces are.
So what are you finding? What proportion of patients actually open it, and then
engage partially, and then engage fully?
So that's a good question. I don't have the figures off the top of my head.
I would say
that for the most part, they are in between, right?
One way that we built it as well
is that they can't skip from the beginning to the end.
So to get to navigate, they actually have to at least
see part of each of the sections.
And that was one way we ensured that we at least had a kind of
bottom line
of engagement.
Thank you.
Are there any other questions?
Good. Thank you.
Thank you.
All right. I'd like to start
by saying that we've become
very good at calculating risk, but we're still not good
at making it useful for patients and communities.
In many cases, genomic risk
communication changes understanding, but it doesn't translate into
action and improved outcomes. And that raises a critical
translational question. What turns risk
into action?
I'll argue that communication not only is not computation,
it's the limiting step in improving outcomes related to
cancer genomic risk communication.
So principles in effective communication
are clarity, relevance, and action.
So we need to explain not only risk, but what to do next,
action steps for patients.
So this framework shows how communication drives impact.
We start with targeted risk communication messages that make genomic
risk clear and actionable. That activates
understanding, motivation, and self-efficacy,
which leads to real behavior change,
more testing, more screening, more prevention, more
quality care. And ultimately, that's how we achieve risk reduction,
earlier detection, better care delivery, and greater
equity.
Communication isn't just informing or giving information, it's an
intervention that saves lives.
Risk communication matters
as it is tied to clinical outcomes and genetic or genomic and
cascade testing, as well as treatment selection.
Clear messages enhance decision quality,
receipt of quality care, and adherence.
And health communication is an enabling implementation
infrastructure that drives awareness, adoption,
and behavior change.
When we say theory-based,
some people don't like theory, so my apologies.
I love theory and theory-based interventions.
Hopefully, I'll convince you
are good.
We mean we're not just sending messages, we're designing them based on known
drivers of health behavior, like risk perception and
self-efficacy. That makes the impact more reliable
and measurable. Theory-based interventions move health
communication from intuition to
evidence to improving targeting, tailoring,
effectiveness, and understanding of how that change
occurs. So basically, theory-based communication gives us
a clear evidence-based expectation of
how people will respond.
Each of these frameworks explains why certain messages work.
The theory of planned behavior shows we need to strengthen
intention and social norms and behavioral control.
And the extended parallel process model tells us how to
balance risk with efficacy and manage fear
so patients don't shut down or become paralyzed with
fear. And the Ottawa Decision Support
Framework focuses on reducing decisional
conflict to support informed choice.
And the health behavior model highlights perceived risk, benefits, and
barriers. And together, they guide us to design messages that
move patients from awareness or knowledge to action.
And the last theory is the elaboration likelihood model, which
purports that to help patients understand, not
just react, so decisions about genetic risk are
informed and durable. Central processing
happens when somebody is highly engaged and motivated.
They think carefully about the information.
For example, really trying to understand their genetic risk,
what it means, and what actions they should take.
And in contrast, peripheral processing happens when someone is
less engaged, overwhelmed, or doesn't have the
ability or time to process complex
information, such as genetic risk communication.
So they rely on shortcuts like trusting the doctor,
reacting emotionally, or just focusing on
a simple takeaway.
So what does this mean in practice?
It comes down to how we design our messages.
Effective risk communication isn't about delivering more information,
it's about delivering the right information in a way that people
can understand and act on. This sounds really simple, but those
of you who do this work know that some of our interventions don't
actually translate into improved outcomes.
So all of this is important in designing communication
interventions. So this means clear, simple,
and actionable messaging using plain languageMeaningful
visuals and framing risk in ways that resonate with
patients and communities and their lived experiences
and increasingly precision messaging, getting the right
message to the right person at the right
time and getting that message right.
It requires intentionality tailoring messages to different
populations to people individuals, and
reducing confusion and building trust
because ultimately the message is the intervention and how we
communicate determines whether or not people will act.
So one way to avoid these pitfalls, and we use this a lot in our research,
is how we present risk, especially visually Instead of
vague statements like your risk doubles, we use absolute risk, clear
concrete numbers. For example, saying 61 out of 100
gives people something they can understand.
And when we pair that
with visual icon displays or arrays,
we reduce misinterpretation.
Hopefully, we arouse emotions and make risk more
tangible because how we show risk is just as
important as how we say it.
So building on that, choosing the right visual matters just as much
as using visuals at all. For individual risk,
icon displays are most effective.
They improve understanding across literacy levels and reduce
misinterpretation. Bar graphs, on the other hand, are very
helpful for comparisons at the group or policy level, but
require more numeracy skills and careful
design. So again, it's about precision matching the
visual to the audience and the decision we're trying to support.
And this is exactly how we applied this in our Grace trial.
This was a population-based
trial where we recruited breast and ovarian cancer survivors from
five statewide cancer registries and studied
a
risk communication and decision coaching intervention
to actually move them towards genetic counseling and
testing.
So in this slide, you can see here that we used
bar graphs and women liked the bar graphs
if they tended to have higher numeracy levels, where those with more
lower numeracy levels focused more on the
visual icon displays. So matching
people to their preferences is really important because as Sarah
pointed out, one size does not fit all.
So you can see here that building on visuals also help us
communicate more complex information.
So how risk varies across variants.
So this information
is important so that we use both bar graphs
as
well as
individual icon displays for different reasons so
people could understand the level of risk associated with different
variants in this bar graph. And we test these messages through in-depth
interviews as well as focus groups.
So once we communicate our risk clearly, the next step is
structuring the conversation about risk.
We use a simple four-step framework.
First, we start with the core message, what this means, the
implications,
how this may affect care, and then next options, what
choices are available. And finally, the next steps, what
to
do to move forward. And this structure helps make the complex
information manageable and supports more informed,
confident decisions.
And this is how this framework can translate into real conversations in
practice about germline testing.
We start simply by saying what the test looks for, then
clearly explain the result and what it means, and then the next
steps. We also extend the conversation,
highlighting implications for family members.
And again, we close the loop by checking for understanding,
because the goal isn't just to deliver the results, it's to ensure
patients understand and engage and know what to do.
And just as important as what to do is what to avoid.
There are common pitfalls we see.
Providing risk without context, using vague or alarming
language or over-promising outcomes.
These types of messages can confuse, increase anxiety,
and ultimately reduce trust and follow-through.
So precision messaging isn't just about clarity, it's about
getting it right
and avoiding getting it wrong.
Similarly, when communicating tumor testing,
clarity is key.
Very complex
for patients and their family members to understand.
We start by distinguishing this.
The test looks at the tumor, not inherited genes.
So distinguishing between somatic mutations and
germline mutations is of paramount importance.
And then we focus on action, how results may guide the
targeted treatment, and we acknowledge uncertainty.
Some findings may not be definitive.
Again, the goal is clear, honest communication that supports
informed treatment decisions.
For immune marker testing, we also focus on clarity and
expectations. We might say these results help guide how
likely a treatment may work, but it doesn't guarantee it.
And importantly, they're used alongside the full clinical picture for
the best treatment decision for that individual
patient.So
this is where patient-centered framing becomes really critical.
We balance clarity with expectation setting
and being honest that not every tumor has a target,
while reinforcing that the results will still guide care no matter what
the result. And importantly, we pair hope with realism
so patients feel informed,
supported, and prepared for whatever comes next.
And finally,
none of this works without community-engaged research.
If we want risk communication to be effective, it must be
carefully grounded and practically relevant, not just
scientifically accurate.
Community-engaged research helps us close the
ancestry gap or cultural gaps, build trust
that lasts, and ensure messages reflect real-world
language and lived experiences. Because ultimately,
communication only works if it resonates with the people we're trying to
reach.
And this slide shows where community-engaged research is essential
across the lifestyle of building tools.
At creation, it ensures the tool reflects the community's voice or the
patient's voice, driving engagement and retention.
In testing, it surfaces blind spots,
ensuring real relevance to user concerns.
And in an evaluation, it shifts beyond clinical metrics to
equity and real-world impact. The bottom line,
community-engaged research moves us from building tools that work
to building tools that matter.
So community patient input improves relevance and
trust, and the addition of navigators, especially for
the underserved populations, can help reduce structural barriers
that communication interventions alone
can't address and improve uptake of services and better
quality care. So learner verification is a strategy that we
use when we're developing tools and messages,
because it is a process of testing patient education materials with the
target audience to ensure they are understandable, relevant,
and support informed action.
So when I have students working in my dry lab
or junior faculty, I tell them that what we start with is going to
look nothing like what we end up with.
We do a lot of community engagement.
We get a lot of bi-directional feedback.
And then it's an iterative process, and it's a lot of work,
but it makes the intervention better and more effective.
So we use a multimodal approach
to maximize impact. So prints and visual aids help improve
comprehension, while storytelling increases relevance
and connection.
And digital platforms allow for layered personalized information,
and chatbots like LEAH in our PROPEL
trial, which was a intervention
designed for Black patients to educate them,
empower them, and activate them to have a
conversation about tumor testing and immune
therapy as well as targeted treatment.
And also we had a clinical trials module.
And this was culturally tailored for Black patients because they're most profoundly
affected
in terms of disparities related not only to germline testing, but also
to targeted treatment, including somatic testing
of the tumor. So together, these approaches ensure information is not
just delivered, but understood, retained, and actionable.
So this framework shows how to match communication mode to
specific patient needs in both germline and tumor testing.
Video and animation helps improve
understanding and makes complex science
less intimidating. While printed material guides
serve as ongoing references that the patients can use at home,
they can share with relatives or other social network
members, and is available anywhere for them.
They carry it around. And interactive tools and question prompts help patients
engage more actively in clinical decisions and
discussions with their healthcare providers.
And peer testimonials
provide emotional variation and validation and
realistic experiences. And finally, chatbots
extend support beyond the clinic, providing real-time answers and
facilitating family communication and facilitating
cascade testing surrounding hereditary cancer risk.
So this is an example of how we translate these principles into
one of our chatbots.
We have several... Well, we have more than several chatbots now.
But Alex is the foundational chatbot or digital health guide as our
community
scientist helped us
craft a name because chatbot didn't sound so friendly and people have a knee-jerk
reaction when they hear chatbot. So this chatbot,
or digital health guide, was designed to educate and support decisions
about hereditary risk and genetic testing.
Alex provides tailored multimedia
content, including videos, guided information,
information they can print, question prompts, interactive
support to help users understand their options and move towards
testing.So we have a guided flow you can see here in the
menu. This is at a hybrid AI-powered chatbot where we use
a large language model
constrained knowledge base. We provide the knowledge base with credible,
accurate information that's vetted by genetic specialists
and oncologists. And patients really like
interacting with
Alex in this case. We have another one that's tailored for black cancer
patients for germline testing, and her name is Gita.
She's a genetic education digital assistant.
So Alex was developed, and so was Gita and our other chatbots
using community-engaged approaches to ensure that it's
relevant. So the goal is not just to access information
but make informed and confident decisions.
So we did focus groups, as I mentioned.
So the focus groups identified key features of our
chatbots, including the need for culturally relevant content,
clear risk communication,
privacy protections, and actionable steps.
So the process ensured that the intervention wasn't just evidence-based,
but truly responsive to the needs of those that we were aiming to
serve.
So Alex goes beyond education, not only provides risk information,
but actively addresses common barriers
and concerns and preferences, including cost concerns,
insurance concerns,
and privacy protections like the Genetic Information
Nondiscrimination Act. And at the same time, she facilitates
next steps. She guides patients through logistics like insurance
submissions, so patients can upload their insurance cards.
They can make a decision. They don't need to go see a genetic counselor.
They actually get educated and make a decision.
They have an option to see a genetic counselor, but I can tell you that the vast
majority, over 98% of our patients
opt to get genetic testing if they so choose genetic testing
rather than seeking an additional health appointment
with a genetic counselor. Alex also will
disclose test results for those who test negative or have a variant of
unknown significance. And then we've more recently developed a
family sharing module as well as a cascade testing module
where those who are found to have a pathogenic variant
they can input their relatives' information, send them
information about their genetic test results, what it means for
them, and then we have the chatbot with the same multimodal
tools that educate the relatives of the cancer
patient. And those bots will actually
allow the relatives to upload their insurance card, make a decision, see a
genetic counselor if they so wish, and then get cascade
testing, and then get their test results.
So it really streamlines care delivery in this regard.
And Alex also addresses barriers.
So there's a conversation about barriers and strategies to
help overcome the barriers.
So our usability findings. We do a lot of user and usability testing.
Why this approach works. Participants consistently describe the
chatbot as clear, easy to use, self-paced,
allowing them to engage on their own terms, and importantly, they emphasize
the respectful conversational tone.
So patients can use voice or they can type in and chat with these
bots. They also noted that Alex or Gita
answered their questions and even anticipated new ones
and deepening their understanding.
And critically, it provided immediate access to information, increasing
autonomy, and reducing delays in clinical care.
And overall, these chatbots aren't just usable.
They build trust, understanding, motivation, and then
lead patients to action.
So to drive action, we need to structure communication in a
stepwise way. We start with the core message and then explain
why it matters, and then present available options,
and then identify next steps and work with the patient in
overcoming barriers and
to get to the next step.
So in our work, we apply some other communication strategies
such as motivational interviewing techniques to meet
patients where they are in readiness in making their decision.
So we use a simple one to 10 scale
called the readiness ruler in the MI world where we assess how
ready someone is to proceed with genetic testing.
So we match our messages to their stage of
readiness. So somebody who says, "We're not ready," we're not going to tell them,
"Oh, we're going to make an appointment to see your doctor or a genetic counselor,"
or refer them to a bot to help facilitate testing.
And then we use a strategy known as implementation intentions
or action planning, and this is designed to close the intention to
behavior gap. Many people say they intend to perform a health
behavior or get genetic testing or talk to their doctor about
tumor sequencing, but they never follow through with it.
But there's a strong body of evidence that shows that
patients who state
what's important for them in making this decision,
what they're going to do, when they're going to do it,
and write it down and are reminded of what they said
are more likely to change their behavior in a positive way.
So ultimately, we must measure how our communication interventions
work.So we can assess comprehension through validated
quizzes, teach-backs.
We can target our theoretical purported
mechanisms.
We can help reduce decisional conflict or decision
regret, so we're promoting high-quality
decisions. And then we assess process and outcome metrics such as
testing uptake, family communication, and cascade testing rates.
And this slide just shows how we get under the hood.
We do a mediation analysis to really try to
understand how our intervention worked and address
the targets that we aimed to target.
So key takeaways.
Communication is implementation infrastructure in
genomic oncology. We use evidence-based techniques.
We measure outcomes. We co-design with communities to
ensure equity and uptake in better care and
leverage clinicians and health systems and leverage
community-based
and population-level resources to reach the populations.
Because when communication is done well, it doesn't just inform, it drives
action and improves outcomes. So thank you for your attention, and I'm happy to
answer questions.
Hello. That was a wonderful talk. So I totally understand
that people are a little apprehensive to have these kind of really important
conversations with chatbots. Maybe I missed this,
but do you actually have data or are there studies that have
actually been done that shows that when you give the bot a
human-like name, that makes people more comfortable with having
these kind of discussions?
Yeah, that's a great question.
We haven't studied that, but intuitively, we
knew that from other
behavioral and communication literature.
But we do
a lot of community-engaged research, as I mentioned.
We do have our community patient advocate
advisors as well as we do focus groups and user testing.
And so we ask them about the name. And usually,
except for Alex, all of our names really have an acronym.
Like LEAH, you saw Leading Health Equity for our PINPOINT trial.
So they help us with that, what resonates with them.
And then we also test the voices because the voice
matters.
Mm-hmm.
So we were really pleased to know that people or patients, when we actually got
into the field to do these trials,
liked the voice. They felt it was conversational.
They felt like they could relate to whatever bot
it was. Yeah.
Thanks.
Thank you.
All right. No other quest-- Oh, I see a question here.
Hi. So I really liked
your, I think it was part of the Catalyst
study where you had a curated AI
platform with only kind of
expert-approved high-quality information.
Are there other resources like that for people to use?
Because I'm sure you know lots of people are just kind of going to
AI and asking medical questions. So is this something
that is being developed on a larger
scale?
Yeah, I don't know. I'm sure people are doing outside of our
group. Some people are using OpenAI where we really worry about
hallucinations. You can imagine what it could be like giving the wrong
information, misinformation. So the knowledge base
was supplied with credible information. It's a lot of work for us.
We do that, and then we drill it down.
We check reading level, literacy levels,
and some of the messaging. And then through AI,
this large language model, it gets trained.
It gets better and better as it answer questions.
We monitor it behind the scenes. So early on, even though we had a constrained
knowledge
base, we had one man, a patient,
ask if, it was Gita actually, could help him with his banking.
He was like playing with it. And so then we
fixed it right away. And we trained Gita or Priya or
whoever the chatbot is to answer the questions that
she's capable of answering. "I'm sorry, I can't
answer that question. I can only answer questions about hereditary cancer
risk and genetic testing."
We had another man, he asked if Alex could help
with his constipation. Well, same thing.
We had the same kind of response. So we monitor behind the scenes for
hallucinations. And using our strategy
and
a good trained knowledge base, we haven't had any
hallucinations that were misinformation about genetics and genetic testing.
But we track it over time because this is all
relatively new.
Right. Thank you.
Hi. I was interested in knowing how receptive hospitals and
clinics are to using these sort of chatbots and implementing them with their
patients, and if they've been very receptive and what kind of feedback they've
given on the usages of things like this.
Yeah, that's a great question. So,
as a population science researcher, we had to break down a lot of barriers to get
through our health system legally and all of that.
They were more receptive because they can see that it is
going to improve quality of care. We have pilot work.
So for our Catalyst study, small trial, it's going to be published next month.
There's an embargo because of an ASCO-related presentation in
Singapore.
So it's a small trial, but 75% in the
Catalyst or the chatbot arm proceeded with genetic
testing, and like 6% or
7% in the control arm, which got enhanced usual care.
They received a letter letting them know they were at increased
riskFor hereditary cancer and the availability of genetic
testing through our Life Center Hope Clinic, which is a
genetic clinic.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Hi.
Hi. Thank you so much for the presentation.
I'm curious how you think about...
I notice the way that you designed this study has a lot of respect for the fact
that people may not choose to do it.
Mm-hmm.
And I
sit on it from the other end in that I sort of work in this field, and so I advise
a lot of patients, and they're like, "Should I do this?" And the answer is yes,
because
we know that, and even helping family members
navigate this choice. I
remember with a family member, I went and we got five different opinions about his
cancer. And three of the doctors we saw were like, "Yeah,
it's probably not actionable if you got testing, so like don't worry about doing
it." And because I work in this field, I pushed for it, and then turns out
that was wrong and he definitely should have gotten testing.
And because he had access to me, we were able to get
it. So I'm curious, as you design these things,
I noticed that you didn't say, "We're trying to create an intervention that gets
people to do this."
Mm-hmm.
And so how do you
sort of balance autonomy and respect for people's decisions and the
fact that we do want to encourage people to exhibit health behaviors that
help get them better outcomes? And sort of do you feel that tension?
How do you balance it when designing an intervention like this?
If this was 15 years ago, I would say I'd feel more of the tension.
So I'm old, you can tell by the color of my hair, I've been in the business a long
time. And when I started, genetic counseling was
non-directive.
So
now we have evidence that genetic testing is good
and it works. We've studied the harms, the ethical issues, and so this
is more of a motivational intervention, but we do respect patients'
choices. So they get to
the end of the required information because we give
the minimal intervention that mimics a
genetic counseling session, and then additional information if they want it.
So they don't get information overload if they don't want too much.
So then they get to the point where they make a decision.
Alex or whoever the chatbot is says, "Would you like
genetic testing? I can help facilitate that." They say,
"Yes."
They can say, "No, I'm not sure,"
where we give them time to make that decision if they want to talk to their doctor,
if they want to talk to their relatives. Most don't choose that.
Most make a decision to go forward,
and those that
are unsure, we also offer them the option to help facilitate
an appointment with a genetic counselor.
And then they can say no,
right there. So we don't push them, but we use these
motivational strategies, right?
The risk communication, what it means for them, why it
matters, actionable steps, and then get them to the decision.
So it is a little more directive, but we still
value patients' choices.
I know we might be short on time, but just-
We are
... to ask about the LLM. What's the base model that
you use for it? And it sounded like you use a combination of a RAG and
a fine-tuning approach to actually develop
the model over time before you launch.
And so I'm curious, you mentioned post-deployment monitoring, but sort of
before you deploy, what sort of red teaming activities or evaluation do you do for
model breaking
and sort of jailbreaking tests before you actually put it
into a study?
Yeah, that's great. So
we do implement all these strategies like guardrails, right?
What it can answer, what it can't, and test
the messages with our group and our genetics
team to make sure. So we work with a company that does all the programming
and does the
training, so they're the informatics experts.
All right. Thank you everybody. We're short of time, but we really appreciate your
participation and engagement.